there's a deluge of stories at this
point about Donald Trump and Russia and
the insanity that took place and
hopefully were Sunday going to learn
about it but I want to reek of set it up
for you here because there's been some
very interesting revelations about who
knew what and when that surfaced over
the last 24 to 48 hours we know now
widely reported we know I don't even
know what I mean by we know now Michael
Flynn has been indicted you lied to the
FBI in the Russia investigation we know
that Michael Flynn had numerous contacts
with Russians and a big question that we
still have not really gotten an answer
to is did Michael Flynn act on his own
or was he directed by the Trump
administration to make these contacts
with Russians and there's another
question which is even if he had acted
on his own how aware was Donald Trump
about what Michael Flint was doing how
aware was the rest of his team about
what Michael Flynn was doing the New
York Times has a great report about this
which points out that if you look at
recently released emails about this
combined with interview transcripts and
court documents that are part of Michael
Flynn's indictment it becomes more and
more difficult to come away believing
that this was Michael Flynn acting alone
because we now have an email written by
Donald Trump transition advisor katie
mcfarland on december 29th of 2016 she
wrote that Obama sanctions against
Russia would be bad for the Trump
administration and that Russia quote has
just thrown the USA election to him him
being Donald Trump now any reasonable
person most of the people in our
audience Pat maybe Pat certainly me for
sure if we read this we say it's very
clear that katie mcfarland is writing
that it is an undeniable reality that
russia has helped donald trump in the
election now the white house there was a
white house lawyer asked to comment on
this and the white house attorney said
no no no what katie mcfarland meant is
that democrats are saying that Russia
helped Trump she's not actually saying
that Russia helped Trump well certainly
does it seem that way from what's been
released that is a very weird
explanation but we don't have to wonder
and speculate we have a screenshot of
katie mcfarland
which I have up on the screen for you
and she says very clearly my take Obama
is doing three things politically the
third of which is box Trump in
diplomatic lis with Russia if there is a
tit-for-tat escalation Trump will have
difficulty in improving relations with
Russia which has just thrown us a
election to him there is nothing there
that suggests that just this one piece
of bullet point number three that katie
mcfarland wrote is her saying this is
the democratic portrayal it is her
saying it period and the released emails
also show that as soon as President
Obama moved to kick 35 Russian diplomats
out of the United States as punishment
for Russian interference in the election
the concern of Trump's advisers was how
do we smooth this over with Russia the
top priority when mr. Obama said we're
gonna kick out these diplomats was we've
got a smooth over our relationship with
Russia because Russia is not going to
like this in another email katie
mcfarland wrote that michael Flynn would
be speaking with sergei kiss lyac the
russian ambassador so already the idea
that only Michael Flynn was operating
inside this bubble it's impossible right
katie mcfarland knew she was emailing
others about it if only Michael Flynn
knew you wouldn't have emails from katie
mcfarland to third parties talking about
flynn meeting with russians and the list
of those who say who are listed as as
being looped in to what was going on
include former press secretary Sean
Spicer former chief of staff Reince
Priebus former chief propagandist or as
he called himself advisor Steve Bannon
these people all were in the loop so the
part at which we move from possible
obstruction of justice to possible
criminal conspiracy is when we
undeniably confirm that all these people
knew and they were immediately working
on the removal of Russian sanctions as
soon as Donald Trump's inauguration took
place which we learned that they were
doing poetic justice could we say poetic
justice or irony I don't know what to
call it Michael Flynn spoke at the RNC
and led a chant of
hurry up referring to Hillary Clinton
he's since been indicted and pleaded
guilty Donald Trump has been obsessed
with Hillary's emails for years and it
might be emails that end up bringing him
down
yeah or Obama warned Trump not to hire
Michael Flynn now the ultimate irony to
that is the ultimate irony which is if
Donald Trump wasn't so ideologically
committed to not doing anything
President Obama suggested he might have
taken Obama's advice and not hired
Michael Flynn to begin with discuss this
with us on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t
so today's program is sponsored in part
by wink comm WI and c-calm I don't know
if you're like me and many people in the
audience are nothing like me so you know
take this with a grain of salt but I
don't know a thing about wine I can't
tell whether something is more or less
oaky or whether it has full body or a
great body or a slim body or whatever I
don't know anything about it but I would
like to at least be able to have wine
that I like and when you go to wink calm
and actually you can you can support our
show and get $20 off by going to try
wink calm slash Pakman that's WI and see
you get asked these basic questions that
help identify what your wine palate is
so do you like coffee or not what kind
of coffee do you like what other flavors
do you like more or less and then the
wink system will identify wines that
would probably fit within your palate
and then it sends them to you delivered
right to your doorstep and if you don't
like them there is a 100% satisfaction
guarantee you never pay for a bottle
that you don't like never any membership
fees you can skip any month you can
cancel anytime and maybe if you are as
wine challenged as I am the wink program
can help you get wines you really like
and then you can actually bring them
places socially and say oh this is a
whatever and sound like you know
something about it save 20 bucks go to
try wink comm slash Pakman that's t ry
winc dot-com slash PA k ma n